- I think it's gonna taste
like a late night snack
after a pro wrestling match.
(upbeat music)
- What drunk person put
that combination together?
- Why that's all I can say, is why?
- I don't know, but for
some reason I think that
it would be good for you
because of protein purposes.
- I'm from the south and I
feel like people from the south
would be like, totally down.
- Oh yeah.
- I think what we're learning now,
is that America would
put anything in a shake.
- [Voiceover] Eww!
- What are these lumps?
- Please don't (beep) stick that in.
- They're like dipping buddies.
- Are you getting like black spots?
What is that?
- Ah, shame?
- Mmm, oh.
- Well I like the beef jerky part.
- Yeah, I like the beef jerky.
- Oh hey, that works!
- I could be a part of this.
- I imagine this is what making out
with a lumberjack tastes like.
- You've just ruined all
of my lumberjack fantasies.
- You reckon it just tastes
like straight up caramel?
- Mmm, it does, now that
you put it in my head.
- This is a drink for
like, a baseball coach.
- A little league team.
- I would prefer an intravenous
protein injection over this.
- It's kinda like
putting bacon on a donut,
like you don't think
it'll work, but it works.
- I think experimentation is good,
but not with meat sticks.
- What do you think
this says about America?
- We have a long way to go,
but also the way we're going is terrible.
- I think we got there,
I think we went that way.
- No we're there, we're there.
- I love beef jerky, and I love ice cream.
If it aint broke,
Don' fix it.
- Don't fix it.
- There're people that like to
have sex in mascot costumes.
Like this is for somebody,
somebody likes this absolutely.
(upbeat music)